a massive rescue and relief effort is
underway right now in the Bahamas where
there is widespread devastation at least
20 people were killed there and our lead
national correspondent David beg no
traveled to the hard-hit Abaco Islands
to get a first-hand look at the
destruction he joins us now from the
Bahamian capital of Nassau David what
did you see
well Tony what we saw was people sitting
on the tarmac in Treasure key waiting to
be rescued we're in Nassau which is the
capital of the Bahamas and there are
more planes on the tarmac this morning
than there were yesterday every one of
these aircraft is being used to either
deliver aid or to pick up people we were
able to get five seats on a medical
charter that was looking to find people
they dropped us off on what was an
abandoned runway and when we landed
there were close to three dozen people
waving for help never ever seen anything
like this just just so far beyond
anyone's imagination shock and horror
[Music]
while waiting to evacuate the island of
treasure kay locals told us their
stories of surviving hurricane durian
the wind sounded like a huge tornado
to another house the Red Cross says
nearly half of the homes on the Abaco
Islands and Grand Bahama are damaged or
destroyed are you trying to get out of
here
Nancy Albury was one of the dozens of
people who showed up at the airport
asking the various pilots who kept
landing here if she could get a seat off
the island her home was in a nearby
community called Man O'War this is what
it looks like now
she rode out the storm in her home the
house around us we found cynthia gideon
sitting with her three children on the
roof of a building that had blown off
during the storm what are you going to
do tonight she didn't get out last night
the family was going to sleep on a slab
of cement inside of a heavily damaged
abandoned home near the airport someone
had given her in the kids bread and
water bottles the airport is also
serving as a meeting place for relatives
and co-workers when you see what's left
of your home what do you think just
about everyone evacuated from a disaster
zone he is airlifted to the capital of
Nassau which was not damaged by durian
all of the survivors sent here are
triage and either sent to a hospital or
somewhere to find a place to sleep it
was a harrowing experience it's
difficult even to try to put it into
words but it was just unparalleled those
people are also hungry and I wish I
could get this word to them but of
course they have no cell phone service
no television I just heard from chef
Jose Andres who says he and his team
will be flying to Treasure Kate today
with food that they are going to deliver
listen Tony before I toss it back to you
a big thanks to the folks at medic Corps
many of them come from northern Arkansas
they brought their plane here and
literally have just volunteered to go
and land on runways that really weren't
even cleared for landing and
and see who needed help and get them out
uh so many Samaritans doing incredible
work here including the US Coast Guard
which has really led the effort to
rescue folks a lot of important work
there including yours David beg no
forests in the Bahamas David thank you
very much